October 2012 15 hundred journalists are
gathered at the European Council for the
6th summit of the year along the rise of
social media a new type of research and
II reporting tool has become
increasingly important during these
high-level meetings the name is Twitter
journals are very active in Twitter they
need sources of information from where
they can get it if you're a reporter in
this town you need to be in Twitter you
may not want to tweet ever but you need
to be able to follow sometimes when
romboy puts out reports on Twitter first
before delivering them on his website so
I think it's absolutely essential matina
stevis is one of the most successful
tweeters on EU politics she has now been
online for almost three years and a
twitter account has more than 20,000
followers it really has a sense of kind
of community I know it sounds weird but
it does and you get to exchange views
with people that can be very very far
and you would never have otherwise man
the figures tell the story an analysis
of the Twitter used during the October
summit shows that the official hashtag
yuko was used in more than seven and a
half thousand tweets and during the
summit the official twitter account of
the President of the European Council
reached 80 thousand followers I have of
course contacts with the the meaty group
behind us it's not the President himself
informing me all the time because he has
to chair those meetings the press team
and spokesman dig the backer and charts
of treating the statements of President
Van Rompuy he has a clear explanation on
why twitter has become such a success in
EU communication what we are tweeting is
coming directly from the headquarters of
the president and that the information
we sent out is the right information
it's information that has been decided
or is on the point to be decided and I
think therefore is one of the reasons
it's so successful AFP journalist jan
lav aqueous amanda nokia p.m. people
ability to communicate via twitter upon
you eva demo say
univision you could shrivel it with a
diamond gonna pay compensation date we
DNT Sassoon's of amazon computer desi TI
chiamo done at the network kappa des
moines ok vidimo twitter disponible el
bosque de saucé officially to see in
sort of amazon pony but what is actually
a good tweet almost 9,000 people follow
Peter Spiegel the chief correspondent of
the Financial Times and Brussels
according to him the perfect tweet can
have different ingredients I think it
has to be again added value it sometimes
it's scoops that we have that other
people don't people wanna know about
that but sometimes it's just the what's
happening in Brussels at the current
time what's happening in again and the
summit or an event hard news with little
color sometimes even a little bit of
personal fun anecdotes that I think
engages people and and whatnot and so i
think i think that's that's the keys
it's offering a variety not overdoing it
I make sure that I have the same
standards of accuracy of you know truth
of trying to not get my opinion into my
into my tweets just like my opinions
don't show up into my journalism all
three journalists agree that Twitter and
social media in general have a bright
future and communication and journalism
I think looking into the future this
will only get more so I'm hoping that
because this is still a young tool as it
becomes older and more mature it will
there will be less noise and less
confusion about it and it will it will
become just purely more useful rather
than sometimes useful and sometimes just
a way to spread rumors that would be
excellent and I hope it happens